you know when it's like 3:00 in the
morning and you have an idea and it's
the best idea in the world ever and then
you wake up the next morning and look at
that idea again in the light of day and
realize how terrible it actually is have
one of those ideas last night but I
haven't managed to convince myself that
it's not a good idea yet I said I've
it's a good idea yet either and yet I am
still here along the internet wanting to
talk about it it's April which for a lot
of youtubers means vlogs slightly more
than normal month I've always been the
kind of person who's much more
interested in making quality videos over
quantity so it's very weird for me to
you know hold man there's a belief and
then also be interested in the idea Oh
doing a video blog every day for the
next week I've said it out loud now so I
I don't know if it's a bad idea or not I
feel like over the years I've become
much more of a perfectionist than I used
to be and although I feel like you know
aiming towards really good quality stuff
is a good trait to have it hasn't always
worked out for me about a week ago for
example I tried filming a new cooking of
Charlie videos I've always felt like
cooking with Charlie you know has the
potential to be a series and you know
people really like the last one so I'd
look yeah I could do another I spent
like three weeks working on the script
and filming it took lots of effort and I
edited the whole thing and I looked at
it and thought this isn't as funny as
the first one and I deleted it I deleted
a whole video that I've been working on
the Floyd come home just there are then
that's the kind of youtuber I am I make
videos and then just remove them from my
life and think I can do better than that
and then I move on or at least I try to
the idea that I'm only allowed to upload
really high quality stuff to this
channel I feel like is an idea that I
hold more than anybody else in the world
holds it's just for me I want to just
you know be giving you the best stuff I
can but the troublemaker in me also is
just like you know what if I wanted to
upload a vlog every day for a week just
to fill your subscription boxes up with
just rubbish of me just rambling on like
this 50 that's something I could do if I
wanted to there's no rule that says I'm
not allowed to do that I mean it might
annoy you might make
happy I don't know maybe this is the
worst idea in the world ever maybe I'll
look at this video and edit it and think
no I don't want to put this on the
internet just like I normally do but
then again maybe this is exactly what I
need just to get myself up the bum for a
week and just say Charlie mix some
bloody videos why don't you just do it
you know I work all the time I work
every day I work on literally work on
videos every single day so I do work
hard I just don't share anyone the work
that I do and so maybe I should do that
for a week maybe
whenever I try and make a promise on the
internet it never works I always break
it so I'm not gonna promise that I'm
gonna make a video every day for the
next week but I will employ it heavily
maybe I'm just having a YouTube midlife
crisis I'm nervous I'm shaking and I'm
nervous but I'm also excited I feel like
this could be one of the best things
I've ever done all are the worst let's
find out shall we you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool